we got new my dad sickening wallpaper it
is so gorgeous this is the florida vibe
this is what we've been waiting for this
is when we said like my studio is gonna
be like so fun and cool and unique and
special like not like other studios this
is what it was and it is that studio i'm
just obsessed with the whole look and so
i just want to say like if you don't
have anything nice to say
i'm not listening the thing is i don't
even think you have to say that because
i cannot see someone who watches this
show who obviously if you watch a show
like you have taste you have style
you're funny you're interesting you're
beautiful stunning and smart so if
that's you like you couldn't possibly
conjure up a negative thought to think
about this wallpaper because it's so
beyond sickening it's also like
[Laughter]
it's on brand toasty it's on brand
florida like literally line country
safari if you know you know